le sénateur c'est le garant du
fonctionnement des collectivités locales
donc il a son rôle à jouer
le sénateur c'est là quelque chose en ce
moment la martinique souffler
collectivités locales souffrent ma
commune souffle la cacem souffre la ctm
souffle la martinique sur la jeunesse
souffre et encore le gouvernement que
j'avais peut être miser dessus est en
train de nous faire des mauvais coups
maintenant âgé de 63 ans j'ai plus de 45
ans de vie au service de la population
j'ai évolué politiquement au sein de ce
département puisque j'ai été maire
conseiller général président de
communauté du centre de la martinique
j'ai été à deux reprises député
suppléant donc j'arrive je ne dis pas
l'apogée de ma vie mais je dis que
maintenant je me sens apte à monter en
quelque sorte un grade pour pouvoir
servir mon pays est allé défendre les
intérêts majeurs de mon pays aussi